and the other thing that made me a
little skeptical was like them saying
emotional abuse I'm like really and the
third thing again I just kept thinking I
was like if she just if she just
listened to him and didn't take the car
and just got the Uber it would have been
fine and that's why a lot of times I
really put the arguments on the woman
because when we get married we're
supposed to submit to our husbands and
what does that mean that means to obey
when your boss tells you something you
don't go back and forth arguing with him
and if you do that's usually the
employee's fault so if she just listened
that whole thing would have been avoided
but the problem is we've had a hundred
years of propaganda and most women that
are married today have never been told
that their role is to obey their husband